[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALI AFSHAR: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Google Developers
Live with Google Drive.
My name's Ali, and I'm joined
here today with JunYoung, and
we're going to talk to you about
an exciting feature we
launched last week, and that's
Push Notifications.
So JunYoung, if you could start
by explaining, what is a
push notification?
What is it?
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Yes, so Push
Notification is a feature that
sends push notification for
any changes in the API
resources that user made.
So for example, if you want to
monitor any changes to a file,
then you can tell Google to
send notification for any
changes in a specific file
you want to monitor.
And then, if the user makes any
changes to that file, then
Google will send you
notification
right away in real-time.
Yes, it's a great feature.
ALI AFSHAR: So that's
really cool.
So, before we had push
notifications, what would an
application have to do to
realize that a file in their
Drive has changed?
JUNYOUNG GWAG: So, people used
to poll let's say, every 15
minutes or so, and it takes
up a lot of resources.
And also, it is not
really real-time.
So in the worst case, it will
take 15 minutes to show up the
updates, right?
And with this Push Notification,
applications
don't have to query any files or
other things that they want
to monitor every time--
like 15 minutes or so.
And they will get the
updates right away,
which is really efficient.
ALI AFSHAR: How awesome.
So, what kind of things in
Google Drive can a user-- can
a developer subscribe to?
What is available to them?
JUNYOUNG GWAG: So originally,
this Push Notification was
designed to monitor all API
resources, but for now it
supports File and Changes.
So for File, you can monitor any
specific file and changes,
or just delete it or something
like that.
And also for Changes, it
basically just monitors any
changes that users made
to the folder.
ALI AFSHAR: That's fantastic.
So, I can just make a single
request, subscribe, and then
I'll get notifications
when that changes.
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Exactly, yes.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, great.
So, I see as part of our launch,
JunYoung, you wrote an
application that takes you
through and shows you-- it's
more like a Playground--
that shows you how to do these
push notifications.
Can you show that to us, but
first, maybe show us what
extra steps or anything you
need to do to set up your
application?
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Sure.
Since Push Notification sends a
lot of sensitive data about
users, it just sends any user
activity and Drive, it has a
lot of concerns about security,
and there are
additional verification steps
you need to take before using
this feature.
So first let's go to Push
Notifications documentation--
it's devlopers.google
.com/drive/push--
and you'll see that you need to
register your domain first.
So first what you need to do is
to go to Webmasters Tools
and verify your website, verify
that you are the owner
of this website through
this tool.
You can basically add a site and
do some verification stuff
and your website will
show up like this.
And then, when you're done with
the verification step,
you need to go to
APIs console.
And also, [INAUDIBLE] any other
things that you have to
do to drive APIs, you need to
do some special verification
step called Notification
Endpoints.
It will be on the bottom
of the API Access menu.
If you click Edit on it, you
can see a text box that you
can put your domain into.
So, I want to verify that I am
the owner of this URL, and I
want Push Notifications to
be sent to this URL.
And I'll have to put this into
the text box and update.
And from now on I can send push
notifications to this URL.
And also, it is very important
that you use HTTP SSL, because
it should be encrypted, right?
ALI AFSHAR: So let's just say
that again one more time, it's
very important--
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Yes, you
should use SSL.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, do we even
support sending notifications
to non-SSL endpoints?
JUNYOUNG GWAG: No, if you even
try that, you'll get 400, no,
you're not using HTTPS.
ALI AFSHAR: So normally we don't
try and do that, and
force you to do something
because we think
it's best for you.
But in this case, like
with all our APIs,
you must use SSL.
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Yes, it is really
important that users
feel comfortable with
their privacy.
And then, now that you're set up
with all the configuration
of domains, then you'll
have to go to
register your channels.
You can do it by appending,
/watch to the resource you
want to monitor.
So if it is a File, then it
can be, file/fileID/watch.
Or, if you want to watch the
Changes, then it will be,
changes/watch.
ALI AFSHAR: Or if you're using
our client libraries, of
course, those methods
are built in, so
you just select them.
They're part of our generated
client libraries.
So it's a regular API method
with a regular token, and you
use that and the subscription
is active.
JUNYOUNG GWAG: It is.
ALI AFSHAR: So what does
the request look like?
JUNYOUNG GWAG: So there are
three mandatory fields for
this request.
First is ID.
This is the ID that you provide
to Google Drive, and
it should be unique.
So you can use things like
UUID, or anything that's
unique that you feel comfortable
with, like maybe a
database key.
ALI AFSHAR: Wow, you've got a
perfectly consecutive UUID.
That's amazing.
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Yes, what a
coincidence, isn't it?
And also, there's a type.
For now we only support Webhook,
so we're just sending
notification to your URL.
And there might be some
additional support for other
types, but for now, anyway you
should send Webhook for type.
And also, address is the
endpoint of your notification.
So we'll be sending notification
to this address,
which is again, verified,
and again, HTTPS.
Now, I'll answer these three
mandatory parts.
You can send token,
which basically--
whenever Google sends you a
notification, they'll just
echo your token.
So you can just save any
temporary values that you need
for this token, but you should
make sure that this doesn't
contain any sensitive data,
such as OAuth token.
Or, if you really need to do
that, you should make sure you
encrypt it.
And also, there's a parameter
that you can set to set the
expression date.
By default, I'm not really sure
about that, but it is
like, two hours or something.
And I heard it will be
two weeks or so.
ALI AFSHAR: So we're working
on trying to increase the
default length of time.
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Yes.
So you might want to increase
the time to live, or so that
you can [INAUDIBLE]
the notification.
And also, there is no means of
automatically resubscribing,
so you should always keep track
of the expiration time,
and make another request with
another unique ID to keep
getting notification of
whatever you want.
ALI AFSHAR: So in that case--
just to sidetrack you--
in that case, how, if you've got
two notifications for the
same results, how would
you disambiguate them?
How would you make sure?
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Sorry, why would
I get two notifications?
ALI AFSHAR: So, say you
subscribe to a new one before
you unsubscribe from
the old one.
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Actually, in my
sample lab I had those cases,
and that is where I use token.
Yes, so I saved some unique ID
off the pages for each request
users made, and a token,
and saved into token.
And because token echoes that
value exactly, I can
distinguish if it is from
this user, or that user.
And yes, you don't have to
be confused with that.
OK, so once you make the
request, then you will get the
response right away.
So the responses for the request
will be 200 if you're
successful, and 400 or anything
else otherwise.
One thing that you really want
to take note from this
response is resource ID.
So everything else in the
response is basically echoing
what you have provided,
but your resource ID
and resource URL.
So, this resource ID is the ID
of the resource that is being
watched, and it has totally
no meaning for you.
But you need this ID to unwatch
from the channel.
So you need to take note
of this resource ID.
And from now on, whenever you
get any notifications, you
will get resource ID anyways.
So just keep track of it,
you make sure you
keep track of it.
And then, as soon as you set the
watch request and know it
was successful, you'll
get a sync message.
So, sync message is the message
from the API saying
that, hey, your notification is
successfully initialized,
and now we're going to
send notification.
ALI AFSHAR: So we send the
sync notification to the
actual-- to your notification
endpoint?
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Yes.
ALI AFSHAR: It's like
a mini-notification.
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Yes, it's a
notification that says
notification started.
But it is not recommended that
you use this sync message,
because for many unknown
issues such as network
latency, or anything like that,
there might be cases
that actual messages are sent
before the sync message.
So it's not a good idea to rely
on the sync message to
say that the synchronizing
just started.
You should just assume that
notification started as soon
as you got the successful
message from the request, and
it's better to just ignore
the sync message.
While still you can make use of
it if you really need it.
And then, since you get a sync
message, you'll receive your
actual notification to the
notification endpoint that you
specified from the request.
Now, there is much information
that this notification
provides, and depending on
which notification you
requested, such as maybe Changes
or Files, the response
might change a little bit.
So let's talk about
Changes first.
So if you make a request for
push notification to Changes,
it will send notification
whenever a user makes any
change to any files.
So there is a Changes
resource in API.
And users, before there was push
notification, actually
many applications keep sending
changes in list method to keep
track of what kind of
changes were made.
And it kept updating
their local copy.
And from now on, with this Push
Notification, Google will
send you, whenever there are
changes in the Change
resource, will send the Change
resource ID and self link so
you can visit it right away.
And as a response body,
you'll actually
get the Change resource.
And you can parse it just as how
you have parsed the list
of changes it gets and you can
see what kind of changes have
been made to this Drive by
using Changes docket.
It's the same as how you've
interacted with Changes.
ALI AFSHAR: But you don't have
to pull a server anymore.
That's really exciting, that's
really good for me.
OK, great.
So that's how it works,
but there's more.
JUNYOUNG GWAG: There's
more, yes.
So we need to talk about how
Filed resources works.
So whenever there's a
notification about changes in
File resources, there
will be a simple
notification without body.
So there will be no body or any
contents of the file, but
it will tell you what happened
to the file with resource
states and changed
header parameter.
So for example, if the file was
trashed, in the resource
state it will tell you,
it is trashed, or
untrashed, or deleted.
And, there might be
the case that the
research state is changed.
So that is the case when
contents or parents or any
actual metadata of the file
has been changed.
And then you'll get additional
parameter, X-Goog-Changed,
which is another header
parameter.
And it will have contents or
properties specifying which
part the file metadata
has been changed.
So the way you parse the Changed
push notification and
File push notification
is quite different.
And you can see what kind of
resource state and Change
types there are in
the documentation
right away like this.
And yes, that's pretty much how
you're going to deal with
Push Notifications.
ALI AFSHAR: OK.
So you spent a while writing
an application just
to show this off.
So, can we have a look at it?
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Yes, sure.
So you can actually try all of
these from Push Notification
Playgrounds.
It is pushnotification
playground.appspot.com, and
you'll come to this website
right away.
All you have to do
is to log in, and
authorize with OAuth too.
And you'll be brought to the
notification field, and now we
can actually see the
notifications
going in and out.
So, let's say we want to
subscribe to all Changes in
Drive, and we are
now subscribed.
Then if you, let's say, create
a file in this folder, and it
is successfully saved
in this folder--
wait, maybe I did
it too quickly--
yes, well, as you see, you can
see a lot of notifications
that came to this application.
And not only for all changes
in the folder, you can also
specify the file you want to
monitor, and you'll also see
all of those resource states or
changed header parameters,
and see how this Push
Notification
works in real time.
ALI AFSHAR: Can we have a
look at some of those
notifications?
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Yes, sure.
I subscribed to--
ALI AFSHAR: Do you want to
monitor all the changes then?
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Here it
is, here's the file.
ALI AFSHAR: So we're
just subscribing to
a single file here.
JUNYOUNG GWAG: We are
subscribing to this file we
just created.
And we want to change content,
which will show up as changed
contents, and we can
also change the
title, which is metadata.
And then you'll see from here
a lot of notifications.
ALI AFSHAR: Right, let's just
look at one or two.
Can you zoom in on this?
JUNYOUNG GWAG: I think
so, yes, you can.
Now you can see--
ALI AFSHAR:: So let's
just pick one, OK?
JUNYOUNG GWAG: So here you can
see that research state is
update, and changed parameters
is properties.
This is probably because I
changed the title which is the
metadata of the file.
And also you can see here, it
says update, and the change
parameter has content, because
we apparently changed the
content of this file.
And also let's say if you want
to actually trash this file,
then we'll get--
right away here--
resource state has
been trashed.
So you can trash, untrash,
delete, or anything you want,
and you'll get any notifications
just right away.
ALI AFSHAR: That's
really cool.
JUNYOUNG GWAG: It is.
Yes, so we talked about how
you can subscribe to the
flight Files and Changes
until now.
And, so now that we subscribed
to it, we want to
unsubscribe to it too.
So, basically there are two
ways to unsubscribe.
First is to automatically
unsubscribe by reaching the
deadline of the notification
expiration time.
Or, you can also manually
unsubscribe from the
notification.
So it is simple, no matter where
you subscribe to, Files
or Changes, you'll come to this
one channel stop method.
And as I said, you should
keep note of this
resource ID, right?
And with the ID that you
provided, let's say the UUID,
and the resource ID provided
from the API request response,
if you send these two parameters
to channel stop
method, then it will manually
unsubscribe from the channel.
That's pretty much it.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, so awesome.
So thank you very
much, JunYoung.
So what have we seen today?
Well, we've got a new way in
which your app can be notified
of changes to stuff happening
in a users Drive.
No longer do you need to pull
the Changes feed regularly to
see what's changed, and then
finish the resources.
We will tell you now.
So why would this
matter to you?
Well, you're saving a huge
amount of resources, really.
You don't have to make these
regular requests, you're
saving resources for yourself,
and of course, you're saving
resources for us as well.
And that's always a good thing
because it's going to improve
your latency.
So saving resources, and it's
a much more real-time
notification system, so you
will be notified much more
quickly of things that
are changing.
If you're polling, of course,
as we always say, Drive is a
massively distributed system,
so part of it could change,
and then the effect of that
change would filter down
eventually.
It might take a while, it might
take 10 seconds, it
might take a few minutes.
But this is going to be much
quicker and it's going to be
much more accurate.
How do you register for these?
Well, we send you a web request
to a server that
you've registered, you've
verified that you own the
server, and it's listening
on an HTTPS socket.
We'll send you that request, you
look at what's in there,
and you can decide however you
want to behave after that.
We don't send sensitive
information as such in there,
but you will still need the
users token to fetch this
information.
But still, best to secure it
as well as possible and we
need to verify that we're
sending them to the right
place, we can't just
send them anywhere.
So that's Push Notifications,
it's a feature we've been
working on for a long time.
We actually announced it at I/O
this year and Google I/O
the previous year that we
were working on it,
but it's here now.
Please use it, we'd love your
feedback on it, we'd love to
know what could be improved.
And if you're using it, and
you're having a good time with
it, well, that's useful too.
But mostly, any sticking points
you have, any failure
points, we're really keen right
now to know what you're
doing with it.
OK, so thank you very much.
Thanks for joining us.
Thank you, JunYoung for taking
us through and showing you're
awesome application.
I see you've learned
some CSS recently.
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Just
Twitter Bootstrap.
ALI AFSHAR: Just Twitter
Bootstrap.
OK, well, have a good
day everyone.
Thanks for joining us.
Bye-bye.
JUNYOUNG GWAG: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]